الموجه برد شديدا مصحوبه بسقوط الثلوجر
وانخفاض شديد لدرجه الحراره اذا ما اتجهنا
شمالا اي شمال ايران انخفضت الحراره الى
سالب 20 وفي المناطق الشرقيه الى سالب 12
هذا الانخفاض في درجه الحراره ادى الى
ارتفاع الاستعمال غاز التدفئه في المنازل
وفي المؤسسات الاداريه وهم ادب الى قطعه
عن العديد من المناطق بسبب كثره الاستعمال
ماذا فعل السلطات الى اتخاذه اجراءات مهمه
من اجل اعاده الغاز الى هذه المناطق حتى
لا تتاثر بالانخفاض الشديد في درجه
الحراره ايران عمليا تنتج اكثر من 800
مليون متر مكعب من الغاز لكن الضغط على
شبكه الغاز خلال هذه الفتره دفع السلطات
الى العمل من اجل تخفيض الاستهلاك بما
يقدر بمليون متر مكعب الاجراءات التي
اتخذتها السلطات في هذه الحاله هي تعطيل
المدارس تعطيل المؤسسات الحكوميه ووقف
العمل في هذه المؤسسات وكذلك دعوه
المواطنين الى خفض استهلاك الغاز في
المنازل حتى يتم توفير هذا الغاز الى جميع
المناطق وخاصه حينما نتحدث عن المناطق
التي شهدت انخفاض كبير في درجه الحراره
وهي المناطق الشرقيه في ايران وكذلك
المناطق الشماليه تتحدث وزاره النفط
الايرانيه على انها بدات في ايصال الغاز
الى المناطق المتضرره والتي انقطع عنها
الغاز خلال هذه الفتره وهنا يطرح السؤال
حول الاشكالات التي يواجهها قطاع غزه في
ايران ربما يتم الحديث على ان البنيه
التحتيه ربما قد لا تتناسب مع حجمه مساحه
ايران واحتياجات ايران واصال الغاز الى
جميع المناطق والنقطه الجوهريه كذلك وهي
احتياج قطاع النفط والغاز في ايران الى
استثمارات كبيره تتحدث الارقام عن احتياج
ست ايران الى ما يقابل 200 مليار دولار ان
العقوبات لا زالت تؤثر على هذا القطاع هنا
في ايران الاردن تغير الجزيره طهران